this podcast is brought to you by on it
go to honor.com and look at the great
selection of supplements if you find
something you like pressing code joey
and get 10 off delivered right to your
house what's happening you bad
[__] it's wednesday august the
31st it's over the joint is brought to
you by draftkings listen
um the 11th football season is about to
[__] begin i want you to be ready for
week one action with draftking
sportsbook the official sports betting
partner of the nfl and to celebrate the
return of football
you're going to bet five hours in any
football game
and whether it wins or loses you get 203
bets experience the thrill of draftkings
early win promotion and up to seven you
win bet on any nfl team of your choice
and if your team leads by seven points
at any point during the game you get
paid instantly even if your team loses
listen i'm just excited about buffalo
against la rams for the opening [__]
night draftkings is safe secure and and
reliable deposit and withdraw your cash
whenever the [__] you want and let me
tell you something else
[__] uh fantasy season
with draftkings oh my god what they have
over there so what you're gonna do is
either download the draftking sportsbook
app or you're gonna download the
draftkings fantasy app they're giving
away millions in prizes if you're a
fantasy guy draftkings is what you need
download the draftking sportsbook app
use promo code joey and get 203 bets
instantly that's code joey only at
draftkings sportsbook the official
sports betting partner of the nfl
minimum age and eligibility restrictions
apply see show notes for details but
besides that download the draftkings app
and get money ready to win some
[__] money the joint is also
brought to you by manscape listen it was
a smooth sack summer jack but manscape
is making sure you have a ball
this fall by giving you everything you
need to stay fresh below the equator i
just finished man
escaping my nut sack last week and it
was tremendous my balls of magnifique
geek manscape performance package has it
all the lawnmower 4.0 body trimmer the
weed whacker nose and hair trimmer skin
safe technology to protect you
your delicate holes they're all
waterproof so you can shave in the
[__] shower manscape even threw
in two gifts for their package the boxes
and the shed travel bag which has a
little zipper inside nobody knows
nothing take a look at the shears 2.0
that luxury nail grooming kit it
includes stainless steel nail cutters
tweezers and grooming scissors no more
scratching your lady in bed with those
nasty [__] feet so what we're going
to do is this i'm going to give you 20
off and free shipping with code joey at
manscape.com
that's 20 off and free shipping with
code joey at
manscape.com
it's summersack
so get your [__] together [__]
and now it's time for the joint
[Music]
welcome to uncle joey's joy
so
[Music]
what's happening you bad [__]
welcome to another fun-filled episode of
the [__] joint it's wednesday the
31st of the month that said it's over we
did another month we got four months
left in the year this is my favorite
[__] quarter of the year i love
[__] going all out i got comedy shows
i got a ton of [__] going on but anyway
i have a guest today in [__]
studio this guy uh my wife asked me who
i had in the podcast playing i told her
the most interesting guy i've met since
i've been in new jersey
welcome mr rob schaefer to the [__]
joint
we're breaking this podcast cherry to
boot too so
what's happening brother everything's
great bro thank you for having me i
appreciate it oh man ever since i met
you i've been a different [__] animal
we met through jiu jitsu we have a
mutual friend rob story that he oh he
didn't go to class play he was in class
today he was he was in class okay good i
didn't think he went to class but we met
through him uh you know
he introduced me to uh mr schaefer
because he said maybe he can help you
out with the breathing and [__] you know
i love doing jiu jitsu i just suck at it
but i keep showing up
but uh i think this guy's story is
interesting for anybody who wants to do
anything with their life so
tell us how it started you were stock
broke in the city right i was a stock
broker in the city i wasn't your typical
like yuppy ivy league guy that went to
to harvard and became a stock broker you
know my dad was a new york city fireman
i was a high school dropout and i
actually coached hockey at uh at manor
road in staten island which i'm sure
you're familiar with okay yeah so the
owner of manor road i used to coach his
son at hockey and the owner of manor
road i owned a broker dealer called
joseph stevens in manhattan on 59 made
in lane and one day when i was like 20
years old he's like rob
what are you going to do when you grow
up and i was like i'm going to be a
professional hockey player and he took
me on his side he's like
let me tell you something you're never
going to be a professional hockey player
he's like i was like well thanks a lot
for the confidence you know what should
i do with my life he was like oh why
don't you come work for me i own a
brokered dealer i didn't even know what
a stock was at the time but i decided to
take the opportunity and whatnot and i
went there i worked for 14 years on wall
street i did very very well
uh due to a really unfortunate
circumstance in my life when i was 33 i
had an ex pass away really [__] my
head up a little bit
and uh i decided to spend the next year
of my life on a bender that probably
could have killed the half of the
rolling stones you know
and then at the very end of that is when
i found jiu
so what did you find what made you go in
there
during everything i always worked out i
was always in the gym it could have been
the worst day of my life i could have
been hungover i was just a gym rat since
i was a little kid so i was in the gym
long story short you know these guys are
carrying mats through the gym to set up
this little room in the back
and i figured they were doing like a
yoga room or some [__] like that but one
of the guys i ended up going to high
school with and actually grew up next to
since i was five years old his name is
gus branstad he's a black belt in jiu
jitsu and we wrestled together and he
was like oh it's great to see you you
would love jiu jitsu it's just like
wrestling but with submissions so why
don't you come
so i'm like 230 pounds at the time i
[__] jacked i looked like a big beach
ball like a [__] like all the guys at
the jersey shore you know
and uh i go to the class and it was cool
and then at the end he's like all right
we're gonna do live rounds now and
you're gonna roll with this guy
and the guy he points to by the way his
name is dave zenario they call him super
dave he is uh he's a black belt then
he's still a very good black belt very
big competitor
he's about 125 pounds if that okay i'm
230 at the time and he's he's about five
foot four okay so like you're gonna roll
with him and i tell my friend gus i was
like i'm not gonna roll with this guy
i'm going to [__] hurt this guy i
don't want to roll with him he said yeah
go go hurt him i said all right so i
roll with dave i had 110 pound weight
difference between me and him
he beat the living [__] out of me when i
tell you like probably submitted me 25
times in five minutes and that was
because he was being nice
you know so after that that was it i was
like whatever the hell this guy just did
to me i need to learn how to do that and
i need to learn it quick because that's
never happening again
now seven years later it still happens
every time i roll with him but it's just
you know now you know the game there's
always those levels and he's always up
there um yeah but that's how i got into
it and i really really fell in love with
it
i really dedicated the past six years to
training i trained three four times a
day sometimes between not just jiu jitsu
but jiu jitsu the gym the breath work
that you and i have been doing together
and things of that nature and it's
changed my life in
the best possible way i could ever
imagine how long did you stay at that
school i was only at that school for a
few months uh not for any bad reason
just because i ended up moving so i went
up to north jersey and i was training at
a school called pure mma
i think they're the biggest in new
jersey they have like 1500 students in
rockaway uh andy and mikey maine andy
was uh on the ultimate fighter and he
was the king of pancreas and stuff like
that and mikey's just another young
talented guy but more importantly
they're just
like most people you meet but they're
just two of the greatest people they
built a beautiful facility they have a
great
student base
and i trained there for a long time
until i met cyborg and then uh
transitioned to fight sports and not
training with steve as well when i'm in
new jersey now where did you meet cyborg
so i met so when i first got into
jiu-jitsu i really really wanted to be
great at it and i kind of got
discouraged because i started at 35 you
know and you see all these world
champions out there they're like you
know 18 19 20 years old so i thought i
was very late and it was discouraging
because i was still rolling with younger
guys but i didn't think i'd ever have
the ability to accomplish much starting
so late in my life so i met cyborg at uh
at
nogi worlds i believe or maybe yeah no g
worlds
three years ago i think it was 2019 like
right before covid and i watched him at
40 years old you know when a world
champion actually i'm sorry
i think in the finals of that he blew
out his knee in it
um
but nonetheless last year for example at
40 years old he wins an adult world
championship you know what i mean like
guy's a seven time world champion adcc
champion and he's still winning
at the highest level at my age
so once i met him i was like all right
there's my motivation
i'm going to be the broke man's version
of that guy
he trains in florida he trains out of
miami you move to everything i went down
there to go move okay i trained there
with him i went down there to move he
invited me to join the team
come back and now i'm moving right
moving down
april 15 2020 and i lived in miami i
mean i lived in miami in 2013.
april 15 2020 i had my realtor
appointments to look at places
and [__] cover it happens right so
they canceled all realtor appointments
you couldn't even go into apartments or
houses to look at them at that time
so i said all right you know what i'll
sit tight as soon as this [__] is over
thinking it's gonna be what a week you
know two weeks three a month right then
i'll go move down well here we are now
three years later things are finally
just subsiding and the prices down there
have more than doubled so
i'm still
probably to a fault so loyal to that
team i will never compete under any
different team i'd rather quit jiu jitsu
but i'm training right now with you know
steve and inferno as you know i'm up
here they're super supportive and help
me as much as they can while i'm here
the thing that impresses me the most
about you is
you became a champion
at the age of 40 uh 13
yeah 40 40. and it's really interesting
that after i spoke to you
you're a champion i mean you're a
champion in life because
you put everything you have into this
like
you know the ability that you have as a
stock broker to work and make money you
push that aside
to make to be happy
which a lot of people don't even
understand that concept
they will never think about that you
know they'll never adjust it because
they're scared they won't be able to
make money you took a chance you put
some money away and you said this is
what i want to do i'm going to change my
budget you drive a car like me a subaru
right you kept all the
you kept your [__] uh overhead low
and you've dedicated yourself to
training that's
i think that's spectacular my free the
truth of that is that if it wasn't for
jiu-jitsu i wouldn't have done that
because you know the business that i was
brought up and it was about you know who
has the most who was the biggest house
was the nicest car the nicest watch
bubble and you never were happy you know
you could have made a million dollars
and the guy down the hall made two
million and you know you weren't good
enough once you start training jiu jitsu
as i'm sure you know because you meet so
many people from all walks of life none
of that [__] mattered to me anymore i
was like you know what i'm happy doing
this and if i can just do this
effectively and enjoy myself i'm good
and i did and guess what through jiu
jitsu my business exploded i got into
another business now i'm doing solar
that's exploded just from people that i
met through jiu jitsu
i'm here with you because of jiu jitsu
99 of my great friends in life i've met
through jiu jitsu so it's really uh you
know it's the sport that changes not
just me but anyone you talk to that
really falls in love with it it has the
biggest impact on my life than anything
i can imagine you know i read all this
stuff online about
jiu jitsu as a cult jiu jitsu is this
that and it's really hard to explain to
people
the satisfaction you get from jiu jitsu
i went to karate as a kid i did
everything you know i tried everything
at least one time
when i walked into that jiu jitsu place
for the first time because i had dear
friends that were already in the [__]
game they're masters of this [__] right
and they couldn't get me to do it and
one day i just watched the match
and i'm like i like this better than
that old mma [__] i saw a beauty in jiu
jitsu
that i never saw on anything else like i
saw it in basketball you see it in
baseball there's a certain beauty to it
but jiu jitsu just grabbed me and
jiu jitsu is a life changer for some
people like it was for you
jiu-jitsu lets you know how [__] up
you really are and the things you got
yeah you're going for a blue belt you're
going for this
but there's so many personal things like
for me i was a mouth breather
so we're working on that now right right
no
i mean listen i've got my nose broken 18
times and then you put two pounds of
coke in there ain't gonna help your
nostrils or breathing
i still remember getting surgery like
all the surgeries i've gotten since
and helped me with jiu jitsu but they
showed me that
i'd like to breathe
like i never knew i wasn't breathing
problems right i had no [__] idea i
would walk stairs and go why am i
[__]
out of breath it's three [__] stairs
you know
and then you learn i realized i couldn't
breathe right that's what i was doing so
forget jiu jitsu i had to learn how to
breathe right and then i had a surgery
on my knee and why did i get and i'm
like i'm never going to go back to just
after the surgery are you [__]
kidding me you don't even let the heat
the knee heal no and you got to go back
and the thing i noticed about jiu jitsu
is one thing like i was going to
kickboxing for a while at this
kickboxing america
you know i had gone from 418 pounds to
about 270 and i wanted to keep my weight
there i wasn't involved in jiu jitsu
before but i would go to these
kickboxing places
and i would see these guys with the rash
guards and the [__] knee pads and the
[__] pants and greased hair and that
[__] hitting me for real and i'm like
can i ask you a question what do you do
for a living you're a fighter and i know
i'm a fireman a [__] fireman
you know so it was a little too real for
me like that that kickboxing place it
was like
people were trying to always over prove
themselves right then you walk into a
jiu jitsu gym
and the first day they'll say to you go
with that guy
and as you're going with this guy he's
beating you up you're not breathing
right but he'll stop and go put your
hand here
put your hand over here do this do that
the people you meet that's never been
done no like i never had that before
you know i was i went through a really
bad period for about a year after i
moved here i was confused
and i walked into gracie one day and
[__] uh they were very nice to me you
know and a week later i have to have
knee surgery
and i had this corona fear
i had the corona fair listen man i was
asking somebody the other day how come
all these people haven't gone back to
work
like there's a lot of people like i just
read somewhere else that they can't do
this this year because they don't have
enough employees people don't realize
they're still
amazon there's still a lot of people
that are hiding in their houses guys
yeah i want you to know that
there's still a lot what about all these
people that lost their jobs for not
getting vaccinated now you don't need a
vaccine anymore for anything but these
people still lost all their jobs
well
the thing with me was i i hope like i if
your union and they fired you with this
vaccine you better call them up and say
listen we're taking these [__]
to court yeah i'm union can't [__]
fire me over this these cops that lost
their jobs yeah firefighters it's funny
because when i went to the lbi this year
i met some fire lady like a fire woman a
firefighter that was a female and then
she crossed the street with like 10
other chicks and they were all yoked and
[__] and she was telling me that they
became firefighters doing the pandemic
because all these guys yeah they're
looking they're like the [__] vaccine
they feel like yeah i don't need my
uterus yeah yeah seriously
i'm a lesbian
next week it's okay yeah so
it's so weird how everything has changed
oh but back to jiu jitsu
i was a mess guys
mike would come home and i'm like you
gotta go like i couldn't take it no more
i couldn't i would be afraid to get him
sick or for me to get sick from him a
lot of people yeah i didn't dog that was
my biggest [__] fear with somebody
going joey i'm dying because i went and
smoked a joint with your stupid ass and
i didn't so i didn't encourage it but
the kid called me sean coach sean from
uh hollis grace he's like bro what are
you doing i go nothing my knee was
coming and just exercise at the time i
was going to the gym and stuff
dog i was so scared of coping when he
put me in a closed guard and he was like
breathing on me i'm like i'm gonna
[__] die
i'm gonna die jiu-jitsu ruined my life
he threw me around a couple minutes and
[__] i'm like oh
this is tremendous i conquered covert
fear all in one day yeah i went to
acupuncture
the first day september 22nd i went to
jiu jitsu and then i had the hardest
thing of ever i had to go to the city
for the premiere of the soprano movie
with 2 000 people on the beacon theater
i still remember getting jumping out of
the car and a bunch of people hugging me
and going
i'm dying yeah i'm not going to make it
i'm dying at this movie theater
and
the next week i went to jiu jitsu and my
fear was gone yeah
i went to their seminar and i went
upstairs and there was like 60 people
upstairs oh boy and i forced myself
and everybody was so [__] nice and
people are so cool and
i joined jiu jitsu basically for social
reasons and for health reasons
because i know the people i'm going to
have around me are going to be the best
people 100 this morning i was talking to
a guy from the fbi in my class i'm a
[__] criminal and he's talking to me
for 20 minutes about kids he's in charge
of organized crime
goes to the city every day for [__]
and here i am talking to him a couple
weeks ago is me him and an actual
gangster
in class he only trains in the key
though so you can't see the wire right
yeah
it's just a great thing and now i have
all these friends from jiu jitsu that
call me some of them smoke weeds i meet
the one asian guy we smoke a number from
time to time yeah and it's it's great
and i'm getting healthy like today i
burned
511 [__] calories
that's a lot of calories for doing
something fun that you enjoy oh my god
and i'm getting beat up yeah coach come
on you know i'm getting beat up and
throwing i did get an americana today
there you go i got a simple i can never
get those i could never get those and
that's the game i want to play so i've
been working on just simple americanas
gamoras from side control
and it's just
like right now i want to do comedy part
time but i want to do jiu jitsu full
time yeah that even though i suck at it
i don't give a [__] we were just talking
about recuperation yeah and we were
talking about how i want to lift twice a
week and then go to jiu jitsu three
times a week but i can't do it
like my goal
my goal was to hit five classes one week
and i had four
but that's fine you know what the goal
should be to have as many classes as you
can and still do your best at them like
even when i train you know twice a day
six seven days a week by the sixth or
seventh day i'm not getting really good
training because my body's falling apart
i'm 41 as well you know what i mean i'm
getting up there in age i don't recover
like i used to i'm just a little bit
[__] if i don't train twice a day i
lose my mind so like it's the lesser of
two evils i'm a big believer in like
destroying your body to fix your mind if
you've ever heard that that saying
before you know and when i'm destroying
my body i have no stress i'm happy as
can be all the endorphins come out i
leave that room feeling great then i can
go deal with all the [__] i have to
deal with afterwards you know you know
it was really impressive what really
impressed me about you was a couple
years ago on the church when i had the
previous podcast i don't know me and lee
were talking about something i did about
20 minutes about my day do you remember
that podcast
i go let me tell you
what there's a couple of podcasts no but
that was like i wanted people to
understand like people think that you
just go up on stage at 8 o'clock at
night and people fall down laughing and
you walk off the stage and people throw
coke at you this is what people think
and you go into the green room and
somebody's sucking your dick and
all day you sleep and you party you know
and people have no idea
when you get to a certain level like
okay we see guns and roses now all right
guns and roses are not partying normal
they're not partying they're clean and
sober they're old you know
so what do they do now if you talk to
them like i don't talk to them but if
you look into their day i guarantee you
all five of them are working out i know
duff goes he's a [__] kickboxer he
trains with [__] crazy man
when duff for duff to get healed when
his [__] liver blew up or whatever
ruptured from trekking
he went to
the one of the
best better jet okay so he trains at
benny the jet when he's in town and i
think he takes him on the road on the
tour that's cool i would train him i
would too so you know people think
like a guy like you walk in you got a
nice build you know you're healthy
you're strong they think you just pull
up with your maserati go and beat up
three people and get back in your car
and go home tell me about your day
tell me about your supplement intake so
these people know
the road to a champion well
my day is seven days a week but that
doesn't mean i actually do it seven days
a week you know i do have businesses
that i run it with not so i plan on
training two three times a day every
single day seven days a week and when
people ask me how much i train i tell
them i train every day but life happens
sometimes and i don't actually train on
those days i just never plan on not
training for a day you know like i'm
leaving for worlds on thursday so i took
off today and tomorrow let my body
recover okay i still tell people i train
every day but i didn't train today and
i'm not training tomorrow but when i'm
healthy which as you get older that's
half the battle right i have you know
two blown out knees two herniated this
in my back you know when i'm healthy and
the weather's permitting my day starts
off i get up every morning and i go do a
murf okay
mile run with a 20 pound weighted vest
300 squats 200 push-ups 100 pull-ups
then another mile run now before this is
there any coffee any breaks oh i'm up
before i say any protein 4 30 in the
morning i get up between 4 30 and 5 30
is like my favorite hour of the day the
world is still asleep i have my coffee
check my emails look at jiu jitsu [__]
on instagram and stuff like that and
just get myself mentally prepared for
the day i take a whole bunch of
supplements everything from you know
magnesium salt i take
um uh what is it what is the word i'm
looking for
i'm having a brain fart at the moment
i'll take a peptide called bpc157 which
fixes your it actually regrows muscle
fibers tendons and ligaments so i take
those for my knees and my elbows my
tendinitis and [__] like that
i take heart orine which is another
peptide that helps with your lung
capacity and your endurance i do a lot
of breath work which you know we've done
together and if i if you don't mind me
discussing that briefly so you know as i
mentioned i i do breath work with a girl
named gabriella borges she is [__]
awesome i want to go tomorrow i would
like if she's available i'd love i got
to get you in there let me ask you
we got nothing she is amazing i met her
just like i met her through jiu jitsu
okay we started bartering so i was
teaching her and her awesome daughter
giselle i was teaching them group
judiciary lessons and they were teaching
me breath work lessons
i went there because i wanted to have
you know better breathing i still
compete with guys sometimes that are 25
i'm 41 and they have endless gas tanks
so i'm on my way there i'm like i got
this breathwork coach this is gonna be
great i think i'm gonna go do some
meditative breathing with some nice
music and like relax and everything
that was like the [__] polar opposite
of what we did i walk in there she's
like i walk in there she's got metallica
blasting she's making me do these
diaphragm expansion exercises with like
a 40 pound kettlebell on my stomach
i'm like hyperventilating she's like we
have three minutes left and you know
when you go do something and like
halfway through in your mind you're like
i don't want to be here right now like i
just don't believe everything well yeah
that's how it was but through that it
completely changed my life not just for
endurance that was actually probably the
littlest piece that i took out of it but
you know i had really bad anxiety and
depression that fixed it dramatically
you know you were talking about you know
fight or flight your sympathetic nervous
system when for people that don't know
what that is it's like if someone opens
this door and jumps out with a knife
we're gonna go
and stop breathing and hold our breath
and our heart rate goes up and your
pupils dilate and you freeze and that's
your body that's okay that's when your
body's telling you get the [__] out of
here you're in trouble but that happens
too often in people okay and by by
activating your parasympathetic nervous
system which is pretty much the opposite
that's your body telling you chill out
calm down you're gonna be fine and the
only way to activate is by breathing
so you know through that
everything not just jiu jitsu or just
just life life got better you know and i
do 20 30 minutes worth of breath work a
day i just add it to my everyday routine
it's probably the best 20 30 minutes
that i have every day and now she's
working with bass
um she's a certified actual certified
breath work instructor under dr balisa
and the cool thing is you have guys now
like wim hof right that's bringing a lot
of attention to breath work but all
these people show you really cool [__]
but they don't actually teach you how to
breathe
you can imitate what they're doing but
most people when they breathe or they're
out of breath they take these big huge
breaths with their shoulders and they
fill up their lungs up here right so
yeah if you think about it right your
lungs are shaped like two teardrops or
two pairs like this the parts that are
up by your shoulders they're the
smallest part so when people are
breathing so much to to fill up this
much of your lungs and not this that's
when you start gasping for
right because you're becoming oxygen
starved because you're only getting this
little bit
when you breathe out of your belly not
only does your diaphragm grow and your
lungs grow because they're muscles all
right but that's when you can slow down
everything control
your breathing control your nervous
system and in studies that wim hof has
done they literally gave like him and
his entire team like pneumonia
they gave it to him first and he
wouldn't get sick like he just didn't
get sick they thought it was a fluke so
they took like 10 of his they took like
10 of his students it might not be
pneumonia it was a flu or but regardless
whatever it is they gave like 10 of his
pupils
[__] pneumonia and none of them got
sick and this is like a documented study
you can google it it's amazing so and he
swears that you can actually control
your body's own immune system by
breathing
so pretty cool stuff you know
i've downloaded the breath workout i'm
up to level 18. there you go
i do like
three different exercises in the morning
i do seven days for better performance
they have everything
seven days to lower blood pressure seven
days to [__] reduce stress
the app that the breathing exercise i
think i'm getting the most out of is
[__] the sleep one
you know it's a long inhale
and a long exhale with a pause and then
your five ten seconds you go back dog i
do it in bed with the sleep apnea mask
on to really give me anxiety at night
because the cat's on top of me
so if i'm doing this and the cat's on
top of me i just have to pet her and my
anxiety goes away yeah for sure you know
she's stupid these two cats i have left
or not they're great cats i love them
with all my heart
i used to have a cat that that
[__] knew
when i was anxious
and he would jump on me and stick his
claws into my chest and i would be what
would you do if you know when you're
more anxious i just want to be [__]
alone when you're anxious my wife kissed
me the other day i'm like terry come on
i'm getting anxiety attacked i'm gonna
link her over here for two minutes get
the [__] out of here go take a drive go
take a drink
but i've been in situations where i've
been [__] anxious breathing sweating
hyperventilating and that cat used to
jump on me
and i loved that cat a lot i don't know
i'm not a big guy i'm pushing animals or
hitting i would just sit there and go
finney get the [__] off me and he would
squeeze
his claws into me and i would go out but
at the end of the house guess what that
also happened
anxiety was gone
that [__] knew what he was doing
oh they all know they have a sixth sense
[__] know what he was doing so it's
like at night when i go upstairs now i
trust her i know she's always going to
jump on my side
so i'll do the breath work on my side on
my left shoulder and it pushed me out
guys yeah and it's pretty interesting
i'll tell you why
god works in a weird [__] way because
i have the woop app i [__] love the
wooper it's helped me dramatically but
what it's helped me with the most
is sleep
at the when you wake up in the morning
with the whoop app do you have one yeah
i had one i don't use it anymore just
because i didn't like wearing that
didn't show all the data on it so i use
my apple watch now but i did i have the
loop still i just don't use it anymore
it's really weird with the whoop
remember what is it what does it ask you
in the morning
how rested do you feel no
how was your breathing did you have sex
last night oh all the questionnaires oh
my god every morning you gotta answer
this questionnaire but let me tell you
what they asked you did you cup
did you do acupuncture did you stretch
should you drink all that drink alcohol
but they'll know by your breathing like
i have a sleep apnea machine and it's
got a computer in it so at the end of
the month they send me an email
oh and that has all your data too oh
yeah that has a little bit more in in
depth in debt
but that data will tell you as soon as
you you're drunk
like the doctor would call me like a day
after and go what did you drink on the
18th oh you could see immediately yeah
you could tell because you dehydrate and
something goes it's a heart rate
alcohols
and i was a heavy drinker before
jiu-jitsu like a struggling heavy
drinker especially after my ex passed
away alcohol is the worst drug in the
world the first in heroin the worst it's
the worst drug in the worst
people have no understanding at what
alcohol is going to do to you in the
long run i can't even quit
there's two things you can't quit
without dying alcohol and benzos cold
turkey right
you would draw and die you would draw
you [__] you have a great chance of
dying so alcohol affects you also but
what else goes by your day like after
the supplements and the weighted vest
what else adds to your day oh i come
home usually i have a healthy breakfast
i go get my first training session in um
in between my first training session and
the nighttime sessions when i actually
do whatever work i need to get done um
so you know i still run my private
equity group uh i just got into solar
cells it's been doing really really well
so i get my work done but again i get to
make it on my schedule so that's like my
time to do it and if i have something in
that time frame that has jiu-jitsu or
the gym related to it i just rearrange
my schedule so i'm really blessed now
that i put myself in that position
because i can make my day pretty much
happy every day however i want to
everything you know then i go back and
get my second training session in for
the day and i do try to dictate what my
training sessions are like i'll work on
specific things for the entire week even
if the class is learning something i'll
obviously be respectful and and do the
drills that the class is doing but when
i roll i always roll with a purpose like
not just okay i'm going to try some
wearing them [__] out and if it works
out great i'm going to have some fun i
go there every day with a purpose like
i'm going to work on this this week you
know either something i want to learn or
something that i'm lacking or you know
whatever it is i feel like if you don't
train with a purpose you're taking away
a whole aspect of learning
you know um you know perfect examples i
tell people like
anyone can imitate things like when you
go to jiu jitsu at first and i could
teach you how to do an arm bar right now
and i can show you how to do a really
good arm bar you'll know how to do an
arm bar it doesn't mean you know how to
do jujitsu just means you know how to do
an arm bar my girlfriend has a [__]
awesome arm bar i've been drilling on
her for four years you know what i mean
she has no idea about conceptually
how to do jiu jitsu she just knows how
to do an arm bar you know so i'm very
big on learning the whole picture of it
not just imitating moves or seeing one
cool thing on youtube i'm going to learn
that today even though it has no
relevance to anything else that i'm
doing
um that's it man home by nine o'clock in
bed by 9 30. how many hours do you sleep
on that and it's a regimen i see i sleep
six hours every night and when i do
training yep that's it that's it
i'm good on six hours you know but
it's got to be six solid hours of sleep
you know what i mean when i train the
way i train i go to bed by 11 o'clock
and i'm up at 4 30 or 5 but
i was unconscious it's all rem sleep and
i wake up feeling good you know i could
sleep for 10 hours but get spotty sleep
and wake up feeling like [__] you know
so six solid hours of sleep
hydrated i take tons of salt salt is a
really big thing that people
underestimate
for rehydration and even for performance
you know like
every single time you exercise you burn
an entire teaspoon of salt
okay which is 2 000 milligrams of salt
every time you have a cup of coffee you
burn about 500 milligrams of salt so
like people are at about a 5 000
milligram deficiency of salt every day
and salt actually helps you rehydrate it
doesn't dehydrate you doesn't raise your
cholesterol doesn't raise your blood
pressure it's all [__] salt is what
your body acts it's a mineral that needs
your body to actually hold water
so a lot of people don't eat enough salt
than they don't realize
that's right there you go
but it's really weird even with uh like
liquid iv is a sponsor yeah and that's
got sodium in it it's got sodium in it
and a little heavier on the sodium and i
didn't know why people that's exactly
sodium in it whatever and now i get it
yeah if you look at like you look at
people that run like ultramarathons or
even even regular marathons you know
they're taking salt pills during that
time
when you sweat you're not sweating water
you're sweating salt minerals magnesium
[__] that your body needs
so especially when you have an active
lifestyle you need to take a lot more
salt than you actually would think is
healthy you know i'm somewhere between
five and additional on top of what
regular food has in it and [__] i'm
somewhere between five and seven
thousand milligrams of salt on top of
that a day
wow which is what i'm losing during jiu
jitsu the gym and coffee i do drink a
fair amount of coffee a lot of
stretching in your world
that's probably the one thing that i've
been trying so hard for years to do that
i just [__] hate doing so stretching
for me is like every time i get injured
i'm like it's because i don't stretch
enough i'm 41. and every time i get
injured i'm like that's it once i start
feeling better i'm going to stretch
again and i sign up for yoga classes and
[__] that i never go to because to me
it's i hate stretching it's boring it's
boring it's boring i can train you just
to 10 hours a day and i'll be happy as
can be and to me stretching is like a
flow roll for one round that's
stretching you know i'm loosening up now
now we can kill each other you know but
if you tell me to take 10 minutes and go
sit in the corner and like touch my toes
and [__] that 10 minutes feels like sick
it's like it's like too long it's like
getting sent to the principal's office
like i don't want i don't i don't want
to do this [__] at nights i've been into
stretching
at night right before i go to bed i'll
turn the tv off for like a half hour
before
i do a couple [__] downward dogs i'll
do a couple warrior poses for my
shoulder just to stretch out and open my
chest i'll mix the breathing with it and
then well the other thing i do is i saw
online that some guys like if you have
knee problems
get a [__] olympic ball and put it on
your calf and roll it oh yeah right
above the knee so i get the gun and i do
that and i got the roller and that's a
[__] workout yeah you got a roller
when i finished 10 minutes of the roller
you burn like 100 calories you're
picking yourself up you're rolling
you're like what the why am i breathing
so heavy ah you're [__] right then
your shirt gets caught in a roller yeah
you're trying yeah you're back you choke
yourself now you're choking yourself
it's a [__] nightmare
but i do it i and that's why also what i
was talking about with whoop they give
you a countdown
and i'm like why did i give you this
countdown is this do you have an animal
in the room sleeping with you
all these little [__] things like
there's somebody in the bed with you oh
yeah did you sleep alone they asked you
all these things and it really like made
me [__] think about it but the two
things they ask you
they don't ask you if you worked out
they asked you if you stretched
it was stretching and if there was
breath work yeah and you shut those
right because you tell them in the
beginning like the things that you do
then they ask you if you did the things
you told them that you did yeah right
yeah okay so you do those i didn't know
what breath work really was i would just
i didn't either i really thought breath
work was like she was gonna sit me in a
nice chair and play some of that like
hippie music and [__] right and be like
take a nice deep breath up to three
and then exhale yeah wait till i take
you you're gonna you're gonna have a
half of a heart attack but i'm telling
you it's insane heart
like the app will give you breadth work
what's it called breakthrough the app is
called breath yeah it'll give you some
exercises and then i'll give you
especially in the mornings that's when i
need my breath work so i'll sit there in
front of the computer i'll stand
sometimes like in north carolina i stood
it was really nice i could see the
computer what it was saying but they
have things that you have to switch and
[__] but there's some breathing
workouts like seven minutes long
holy [__]
there's a black dude on there tyrell
that teaches a couple classes he
that [__] dude will put you in
another world man
i love breath work now because it's
amazing and it's helped me it's amazing
noticed it
two weeks ago in jiu jitsu that when i
was passing a guard i was more
listen when you're out of breath you
can't focus
well that's that's that's the whole
sympathetic parasympathetic nervous
system that's 100 right and ironically
when you get nervous you stop breathing
even more when you get nervous you
should breathe right but human instinct
is when you get nervous you tighten up
and you make it even worse on yourself
but i'll tell you what else is bad the
underlying anxiety
when i go to a gym
you know especially with my knee or
something i get anxiety as soon as my
knee does something i don't like that's
it i'm on a different edge okay i feel
everything open up because now i don't
know what's going on my knee am i going
to collapse is this knee gonna [__]
just wilt i don't know what's gonna
happen right and even in with jiu jitsu
i can't lie to you when i walk into jiu
jitsu my anxiety level is [__] high
and at hollis's they have stairs
okay so yeah it's upstairs right between
it's [__] crazy i go upstairs with
not breathing i go polish the stairs
when i get to the top i gotta pee i
gotta take my belt ball
i'm breathing that's the anxiety yeah
that was the anxiety holding me down
because if i have anxiety on the mat
when we do warm-ups it's a [__]
nightmare oh it's for sure but as soon
as i go and i feel comfortable the
windows everything's all right then i
can breathe and knowing that breath work
fixes that [__] what should i for me at
least i'm going to speak for myself
breath work for me helps me with anxiety
big time i was somebody that they carry
around xanax all the time but the cool
thing about taking not the cool thing
but when you take xanax the cool thing
is when you have anxiety and you have
xanax on you you don't get anxiety as
much because you know that you have the
solution to it in your pocket you're
like well if i do get anxiety i could
take this and feel better even though
it's not what you want to be doing well
i still have that it's just i don't need
the xanax anymore i know if i'm going to
get anxious or have the borderline panic
attack or whatever i can stop what i'm
doing go sit somewhere do breath work
for five ten minutes and get myself back
to where i'm feeling great and normal
again
you know i never did that like as a kid
and all that you do xanax when you do
blow or to come down people give you
[__] xanax on the street when you do
blow
and then i don't know over the years i'm
more of a speedier guy like i like you
know i like cocaine we all like cocaine
so
i never tried it i was never
you know i like i like quaaludes i like
quaaludes but what i'm trying to say is
i was never a downer type right same
like uh kids when i was a kid people
would show up with all these pills i was
never really a downer type of guy
paint numb
when i was a kid i tried coding like i
had a twist in my ankle they gave me
codeine i puked for a week so that was
the end of that
uh vicodins make you feel kind of weird
like i tell you what if i was going to a
dodger game i would ask my buddy bring
me two vikings and i'd pop him at the
dodger game and sit there in heaven but
i would go to a dodger game once a year
so it's not you know it's not bad i
don't feel guilty about it but xanax i
had a prescription since 2010 and i
would take them
periodically because you can't take
xanax when you have sleep apnea but you
can't take the [__] strong ones you
can take the ones that control anxiety
but they don't do [__] no they don't put
you to sleep or anything bro you know i
have a high tolerance for a lot of [__]
like if i get sick and i do penicillin
like i get a penicillin shot you're
gonna have to come back next day and
give me another penicillin really wow
since i'm a kid all that [__] works a
little backwards on me
so when the pandemic started a little
bit before the pandemic was when i
started the night after i i tried to
follow uh holly the girl that's a writer
and i got such a bad anxiety attack that
i blacked out on stage for 12 minutes
think of walking on stage in front of
200 people at the world famous coffee
store your hearts beating i couldn't see
and i kept looking through the window on
the side they boarded it up at the main
room when i would be in the in the
original room i could always look to the
side and see the traffic on sunset see
the door guys when they boarded that up
dog i went into a [__] state of panic
and i woke up
12 minutes into the set and they were
[__] on the floor like i had shot him
people were just laughing i'm like what
are you laughing about my anxiety
but obviously i just went from muscle
memory right and i was just killing them
and i just woke up on stage like okay
thank you and i ran the [__] out and i
caught rope
it's the
that was it so i started taking it and i
would put the xanax in my pocket the
little football yeah and then i kept
going to the store but somebody would
give me a joint
and then you forgot to take the zap so i
realized that my wife was washing the
xanax
i was putting
i was putting the xanax in my top pocket
but once a pandemic hit i couldn't stop
taking [__] time
yeah i mean listen they help they do it
when you have anxiety they help
they help for a while and then they feed
into it well oh yeah because i mean you
become dependent on it of course no
it wasn't even the dependents when i
moved to new jersey
if you told me come over to my house i
would take a xanax
and by the time i got the house i'd have
to take another football because you
were still like anxious okay it was
social anxiety so it was social it was a
bunch it was just the cove in fear it
was the covert fear mixed with anxiety
which is not [__] good no believe me
i've been there before every competition
and still to this day i mean i've
competed a million times i still for the
10 minutes before i actually walk out
and compete my [__] vision goes black
i'm sweating and in my head i'm like why
the [__] do i keep doing this to myself
every time i'm like a masochist and
torture myself every month no with this
[__]
not in the league of competitions that
you're at obviously you're headed to the
worlds this weekend but in local
competitions is that a two
elimination uh it depends on the on the
competition this is my problem
i'm gonna get anxiety on the first match
yeah i'd go up against a blind guy and
i'm gonna lose
my first match in a competition i'm
gonna lose i know that it's the type of
person i am but you can't look at it
that way your first match you're gonna
win because you're gonna do the first
match that's winning yeah okay yes you
know what i'm saying no in the long run
you win but what i'm saying is even when
i like went as a kid karate tournaments
you would always get two points on me
a [__] would always get two
points on me and then my cubanism my new
yorkism would come out and i'd kick in
the stomach and i'd win yeah
disqualified i would lose my mind and
kick above the
because when i was in karate it was just
belt in that guy yeah so you couldn't
kick above the thing i'd kick him in the
head with a spinning back
but then that's the type like you have
to smack me once when i play the guy
yeah you have to put eight points on me
okay [__] that's what it wanna
do let's rock i'm one of those guys
right so the first competition i would
do the it had to be double elimination
because i'm just going in there the
first time to hold on yeah well there's
a lot of places that are around robin
you're guaranteed three matches three
matches you know there's one actually
njbjf which is like new jersey brazilian
jiu jitsu it's it's right in i
i think it's at a cba or like one of
these local colleges and that is like
the perfect this is my first competition
competition it's round robin you're
guaranteed two or three matches it's
generally a lot of people's first
competition the chances are you'll be
going against somebody that's their
first competition too and you just get
the experience and i can pull guard you
can pull guard
you can full guard
because i'm not being be thrown i'm not
the guy that's going to talk you out of
pulling guard i play guard there's these
people out here that say if you you know
if you play guard you don't get into
valhalla you know what i'm saying
i'm not one of those guys you know once
my knees went and i couldn't shoot
anymore i'm a guard player so listen
what are you doing this weekend the
world i got yeah i got matt well masters
world's masters yeah and this is the
biggest tournament for jiu jitsu or
because i don't know this is the biggest
ghee tournament for masters so i mean
the biggest tournament in jiu-jitsu is
adult gui worlds uh this is master's gui
worlds for everyone over 30.
um
and then i have in october nogi pants
which i won last year and then in
december nogi worlds which i won last
year
they didn't have masters worlds or
pans last year because of kovit in the
ghee so i only got to compete in nogi
this year they had all of them and i did
second i took second
in guipans in i think it was april and
ended up breaking my ribs like i told
you in the 30 seconds left in the finals
and i couldn't finish the match
so that kind of got me and the guy that
i lost to is in my bracket in this one
so i hope i get him again
get a little chance for a little chance
of redemption you know it's pretty
interesting that um you know 10 years
ago obviously 15 years ago before the
jujitsu revolution it was basically for
us just athletes you know nobody who was
not athletic would we're walking yeah to
a jujitsu place and now
jiu jitsu has grown so much that you see
all shapes and sizes and it [__]
inspires the [__] and the coolest part
is some of the
very very very best guys like mikey
musamechi for example who by the way is
extremely athletic but i just mean by
looking at him is not someone you would
consider like oh this kid's a jock this
kid's a specimen look at him you know
what i mean he's this big
and
he's hands down one of the best ever
ever to live in the sport he's amazing
but it's just so weird how
i i could go online now and look up jiu
jitsu for a 50 year old oh yeah
for a 60 year old what are the benefits
what are the
it's all there and i'm seeing it like
when i left la
there was one other old guy in my school
in the whole school that was just and i
would try to go in to roll with him he
finally came to when they was like we
got to get each other's number because
i'm defeating the purpose i'm coming in
here to fight these 20 year olds and
they're not they're just shutting me
down you know
and now they have so many things
available for over 40 like i just went
to class sunday and they signed two
other older guys and i went up to him
gave him a hug and said you know just
keep coming
you know there was a girl that joined
that she was so big
she couldn't put jiu jitsu pants on i
saw her saturday she's wearing jeep yeah
and wait a year from now on yeah forget
it and you know it's like go at your own
pace you don't need to be scared no more
nobody's gonna choke you
none of those schools want that
reputation no they don't want the
reputation that if mikey comes in he's
been a guitar player all his life and he
comes in here they're not going to break
your [__] fingers you know that's
what and look at all the people and
entertainment that are doing jiu jitsu
when you talk to ricky rocket from
poison
like i knew ricky like from eddie bravo
i gotta enjoy this ricky i don't i never
knew the guy then one day i went to an
airport and there he was and we were
both on the same flight we got stuck for
[__] eight hours so i started talking
to him he started talking to me and i'm
like
this guy's not even a rock star
you've seen what's his name from tool
when he's on rogan he don't even look
like a [__] rock star he loves
jiu-jitsu
more than [__] he loves jiu-jitsu
and this guy i remember when i talked to
rick i go ricky you're excited about
this tour he's like i don't know
i can't do my privates that's what he
was concerned about not that he was
going to make millions of dollars
nothing you're gonna make millions of
dollars it changes you it changes you
and there's days like i tell you what
burns me up the most there's days like i
have a plan like you you know what i'm
going to do this i got to make these
calls i got to write this submit it and
then i'm going to catch a quick
45-minute jiu-jitsu class
like couple weeks ago i [__] had an
appointment at draftkings like a
conference call
and i [__] didn't go to class
and then they called me at like [__]
11 and said we have to push the meeting
back
dog i get more furious at that
i couldn't go i missed jiu jitsu because
you [__] push the meeting back you
[__] like that [__] bothers
me to death now like
so it's it's it's been completely
different for me and after i met you
i really started thinking about what i
wanted to do like how i wanted to do
this
you know i'm gonna lose weight i'm gonna
go down to 250.
i put some weight on last week
on the [__] vacation it was scary
it's right it's cumulative not week by
week it's what happens at the end of the
year and listen man where i was and
where i am yeah it's too many [__]
stories so
and now i want to this is what i want to
do i'm happy i'm not doing comedy as
much as i am anymore you're not very
funny no that was
not
it's so weird how i get my moments of
being funny but i'm not like
my mind isn't dancing i'm in new jersey
now i got beautiful people around me you
know it's like uh
it's like i still like going on stage
but i much rather go to jiu jitsu class
that's awesome three four days a week
you know i'm getting to an eight time
six months away from being 60.
and i saw hollis today when i trained
and he goes you really like it here and
i go you know why
if i was in another school like in l.a i
couldn't go there anymore
they would just kill me you know brow
and right you know all those schools
alberto crain's got a a great school but
here
i could go to the school to i'm 70. i
could just tell i could go there till
i'm 70. because there's a guy that's in
the 60s that goes here twice a week cue
this old man in the world he doesn't run
he just does little slides for his
warm-ups
we play sometimes me and him yeah i go
where the [__] you've been because my
wife won't let me out of the house
dawg there was a 70 year old guy there
that got a stroke during class and came
back two days later
he's got the edge he was a dumb bet a
[__] uh military guy and he joined
there about a year ago i haven't seen
him because i think they he moved he
moved to another school now
but he was [__] 70 he went in there
one day he got a stroke he came back two
days later they said listen man we don't
want you in class like you you don't
understand yeah i need this i need this
[__] i got nothing
that's what happens you either come in
and you get obsessed to where it
consumes your life you know what i mean
like people become drug addicts it's the
same [__] addiction you know it's
just a more healthy addiction you know
but people either come in they get
obsessed or they they just fade out real
quick
you know there's really not middle
ground it's like oh this is okay i kind
of have fun i'll go once a week and see
how it happens you either go in and
you're like this is the coolest [__]
i've ever done or you come in and like
this guy just sweat in my [__] eye
and my mouth right and he had his balls
in my face and i don't think i don't
think this is for me you know
for me that sounds like a glorious day
right
yeah man
let me tell like
you know
i don't understand how to say it listen
let's be honest with ourselves
december whatever july 16th when i first
got on stage for the first time
i had a three minute set i'm not gonna
lie to anybody
in my mind i thought i sucked you know
the first time i got on stage i'm like
but i did have something i had a
presence you know
i had something going for me okay we can
build on it you're not the funniest guy
in the world but we can build on this
okay
when i walked off the site that day i
remember looking at my wife at the time
and going
i gotta get rid of this chick
like right the first time i got on stage
like there's a good [__]
is it because she didn't laugh at your
jokes it just i wanted to be a [__]
guy i knew right there
it's the weirdest feeling that you do
something one time yeah i get you 15
[__] jobs i get your job tomorrow as
a chef at the best restaurant let's go
to cousins okay i get your job at
cousins okay that's the first day you're
gonna go you know what
i don't know joey not for me it's either
for me i like the food you know i like
cooking but it's not for me
i got on stage and pretty much bombed
the first time i knew i had presents
just by their faces how i walked up
when i got off the stage i knew that
like my roofing career was [__] done
my salesman career was [__] done
and this chick i'm married to who i love
she got to go
but she's standing in my way
of me doing what the [__] i want to do
here's the difference with jiu jitsu
first time i walked into jiu jitsu i got
choked i got thrown around i had to run
and pee outside take my top off the
first time somebody mounted me
i was still hooked
yeah of course how can you be hooked on
something like you don't even have
an aptitude
because i think it's easy especially
when you're in a class with some
talented athletes i think it's easy to
observe what's actually possible right
then you talk to some people and you're
like how long you've been training like
i've been training for a year i've been
training for two years but those people
all suck too sometimes worse than you so
when you see what everyone else has done
they all started in the same place and
you're like okay if i just i know it
sounds tacky because this is what
everyone says but if i just keep showing
up eventually i'll be that good and then
eventually i'll be that good and i'm
going to keep getting better
this is the [__] lesson of the day
yeah keep showing the [__] up because
what's up that's applicable to anything
anything like that you know keep doing
it and i think for me
going back to jiu jitsu it was the
lesson i learned from stand-up comedy
listen and it's like anything else in
life you know i could tell you mike
guess what i got a guitar
and i know how to play cocaine and
you're like okay you know when you're in
a band yeah yeah somebody comes up to
you like i learned how to play tiptoe
through the tulips you're like okay
keep going good for you i'm saying bad
i joined jiu jitsu the first day i
choked out a guy you're like okay
that's great you know let's see if it
happens the second [__] day let's see
if you go back thursday you got
beginner's luck you know gambling you
have a gamble at a [__] casino you
always win the first time you're [__]
with a thousand dollars
until the next day and you lose twenty
thousand dollars but with jiu jitsu i
was hooked even though i sucked at it
like i knew this is what i wanted to do
i don't care what i have to do if the
devil comes to me tomorrow and says you
want to be a black dog jiu jitsu and
compete and be the best you just i would
do that before anything else
like i would do that i would sell my
soul to just be able to hang out on the
mats but
but i won't sell my soul
because i i see guys that are brown
belts and they do what we do
effortlessly yes
i can't wait till you come to watch me
do stand up the first time i can't wait
either you're gonna go
bro
you just went up there and
did this and it looked like so easy it's
like when i watch hollis gracie row
he don't do nothing right he's second
nature to him you know he puts his hand
does something you're like
think of it this way for him like if
you're taking a test like like a
multiple choice test and you just have
every single answer before you even got
the test you already know what all the
answers are that's how he sees jiu-jitsu
when he rolls like anything you're doing
he knows exactly what you're going to do
he knows what you're going to do to
defend it which we talked we've talked
about you know what i mean and when you
already know what your opponent's gonna
do before they do it you don't really
have to work too hard you know if i tell
you like joey in three seconds i'm gonna
punch you in the face block it you count
to three and you [__] block it right
that's how they see everything as soon
as they see you move your hips a certain
way open your guard a certain way he
knows exactly what you're gonna do
you know this has been doing it for his
whole life it's second nature just like
comedy second nature to you second
nature to me that's it so i finally got
like i'm a black belt in comedy i'm a
black belt with a couple of those red
stripes yeah like a coral balcony
there you go because you get those every
three years while you're a black belt
you get your first three every three
years every second two every five years
wow then you go to coral belt wow yeah
so yeah i'm like a corbett i could go up
there and just see the game when people
talk to me about their stand up like on
patreon i don't have to watch their set
i know how long you been doing comedy
two years i know where you're at i
pretty much know where you're at
you're just getting it together you
might be really good in your mind you
think you're better you think you're
ready to hang out with rogan and
chappelle but you're really not
you're really not you're gonna go there
and try it one time i know you we all
will and you're going to come back with
not the result you want and then you'll
start to stay in your lane more and we
all do that right with jiu jitsu i'm
going to go over there and train with
henzo really wait till he throws you out
the [__] windows
there's definitely levels to the game
you know
so your first match is friday night
first i don't know what time on friday
we don't know yet my first match is
friday but the whole weekend will be on
flow grappling the whole weekend i'm
flow grappling so i want people at home
to if you have a flow grappling account
a lot of jiu jitsu people watch this
podcast
support my man rob schaefer
and uh
we'll be [__] cheering for you here
thank you brother i appreciate it when
you come back with the title without the
title you're still coming back here
again
to let us know about your experience
brother can't wait i also want to start
doing some type of videos with you sure
people like
you know
if you want to video our lessons you can
video them i think that'd be great
because i love the fact that people of
all aspects all walks of life can do jiu
jitsu and i think people that don't do
it don't realize that you know what i
mean there's a million people that are
like oh you trained jiu jitsu you're in
great shape i'm not in great shape so i
can never do that
you know what i mean so i think it'd be
great to bring more notice i was gonna
quit jiu jitsu but then
i said okay i have a problem with my
knee
i could tap the [__] out on a lot of
things on this but then i thought about
one of the greatest [__] black belts
we have
in the world today which is john jack
machado and john jack has a disability
with his hands he can't really grab
so i thought about him and he just has
to work you know
i've never spoken to him about it but i
know like i've asked some of his
students and they go he's brilliant and
he works his way around it and that's
what made me go back to jiu jitsu yeah i
got one knee down but i still got three
[__] now you have a great half
guard right and i got a great half card
and i could put my weight on yet the
eyeballs pop out
for that it's not fun
i have a great time going and let me
tell you what the main reason about
going to jiu jitsu is guys
to grow as a human being you got to
surround yourself with [__] champions
man honest to god
the only way to sharpen metal is metal
metal sharpens [__] metal and for me
comedy i learned from a lot of great
people from rogan a lot of great people
in my life but with jiu jitsu
man you take a little piece from
everybody in that class every day
somebody gives you something they're the
most interesting people in the [__]
world honest to god and you know i'm a
boring [__] like with people these jiu
jitsu people man i go to my class
there's a cuban kid there's a chinese
kid there's a black dude who was a
[__] a wrestler with uh chris weidman
he was on the same team as chris weidman
so i [__] around with him because he's a
white white white belt right and he's a
good wrestler oh my god
he's not a white boat no
he does
but do you have anywhere where they
could follow you what you do uh just my
instagram is uh rob shafer underscore
bjj but the truth be told i don't really
not one of these people that share all
my workouts and stuff i'm 41 so i kind
of came from that like old school thing
where i mean i'm private i'm private i
want people to see me yeah you know but
if it helps you come to the school yeah
absolutely because you're going to live
you're going to get choked out for 20
days and then one day you're going to
figure out how to make it they get
choked out anymore and if you're 50 and
16 you're just sitting there on the
[__] couch come on guys go to a class
twice a [__] week
twice a week will change your life just
going to eat with different people just
talking about what people do with
vitamins it's it's it's mind-boggling
and you'd just be surprised the
friendships that you make because unlike
some other sports
i i personally i'm not saying this from
a buyer's point of view but i think in
jiu jitsu there's
a bigger camaraderie than any other
sport i played i played hockey i
wrestled my whole life you know i've
been in other sports and i love sports
there's always a brotherhood in the
locker rooms and [__] nothing like jiu
jitsu and now at this point anything
that i do in life
you know if i'm putting a new bathroom
in my house if i get arrested i need a
lawyer i go to the room there's lawyers
there's doctors there's [__] plumbers
there's carpenters you know i got
everything you can ever ask for so
that's why everyone laughs like oh how
can we never come out anymore to my
older group of friends which i still
love very much i just don't have
anything in common anymore all i want to
do is talk about jiu jitsu with people
you know
they don't want to talk about it if you
don't know about adcc in two weeks we
have nothing to talk about that's all
i'm talking about
but rob i wish you all the luck thank
you brother i appreciate you guys thank
you for coming on i love you guys with
all my heart happy have a happy [__]
labor day we'll be back [__] monday
with a podcast just so you don't feel uh
you know at home uh feel lonely and
that's it [__] enjoy your labor
day and we'll be back stay black and now
for a word for my [__] sponsors
all right you bad [__] i want
to thank you all and thank my man rob
schaefer i want to thank mike for
putting together
but i want to talk to you about my
sponsors who are always the [__] best
i love these guys especially manscape
why because you could shave your nuts
you could shave your hair you could trim
your [__] you could trim your
eyebrows manscape is making sure you
have a ball this fall by giving you
everything you need to stay fresh
below the [__] equator listen i
love manscape and i've been with them
for years
they're [__] tremendous you could
shave your nutsack in the shower they
got the [__] uh lotions they got it
all but manscape performance package is
what we're gonna talk about it comes
with a lawnmower 4.0 a weed whacker
nose and ear trimmer and skin safe
technology to protect your delicate
holes manscape even threw in two gifts
to their package the boxes which are
[__] tremendous and the shed travel
bag
take a look at the shears 2.0 that
luxury nail grooming kit it includes
stainless steel nail cutters tweezers
and grooming scissors no more scratching
your lady with that [__] toenail in
bed you nasty [__] so do me a
favor go to manscape.com i'm going to
give you 20 off and free shipping with
code joey j-o-e-y
at
manscape.com that's 20 off and free
shipping with code joey at
the manscape.com is also brought to you
by draftkings listen guys
i know you with another service you're
doing this you're doing that
but it's time for you to try
[__] draftkings it's college
football season it's pro football season
and draftkings is the official sports
betting partner of the nfl
and to celebrate the return of football
if you bet 5 000 in a football game
we're going to give you 203 bets plus
draftkings has an early win promotion if
your team is up by seven at any point in
the game
even if they lose you still [__] win
that's how [__] great draftkings is
plus they have a social page so you can
communicate with other gamblers that
know what the [__] they're doing and
they'll lead you to the [__] promised
land draftkings is safe secure and
reliable and you deposit and withdraw
whatever the [__] you want so do me a
favor download the draftking sportsbook
app and if you're a fantasy guy let me
tell you something they're giving away a
million dollars in prizes download the
fantasy app also
place a five dollar bet in a football
game and get 203 bets again that's
called joey the official
sports betting partner of the nfl and
that's [__] draftkings minimum
age and eligibility restrictions apply
see show notes for details now download
the draftkings sportsbook app and let's
win some [__] money jack i love
you i want to thank draftkings i want to
thank
[__] manscape i want to thank god
better help i want to thank liquid iv
all you [__] i love you in all
my heart stay black and have a happy
labor day and we'll see you next monday
tip top magoo